私があの sns
まぁ実際にソーシャルネットワークを使って色々今してるんですが
まあ new あの今代表的な sns で皆さんご存知だと思うんですけどまぁ
facebook だ
まあ3つ c だとかまあ youtube とかいろいろあると思うんですけどあの
皆さんこの中で sns を実際に使ってらっしゃる方いらっしゃいますか
手をあげてみてください
はほとんどの方使ってらっしゃいますよね
であの皆さん使っている内容というのが結構友達と会いましたとか
あとあの今日は何を食べましたとかあの
景気だとかそういう話題が多いと思うんですけど実はこの sns というのは使い方
によっては自分初のメディアを作ることができると10
自分でこいつ
神の情報を世界に発信することができる
実はそういう強力なツールなんですその辺をまだご存じない方も結構いらっしゃると
思うので私はそのことについてちょっと話したいと思っていますで実は私があのその
ような形で sns の真の力というかそれを
を私が知ったのは実は私が所属してた会社
上場企業なんですけど朝起きて nhk の6時のニュースを見ると
会社が倒産するんですね
で自分の会社が倒産してるのを
朝のニュースで見てワーカー倒産したよてょは締めて自分の会社がマートンてもらい
パティでももう全く連絡にょ
買ったのであの本社の方にまあ自分のオフィスの方に行ってみると
カメラを担いだ人とかあとあのマイクを持った人がもう
メディアの方がもう黒山の人だかりでまるで今回のあの
舛添都知事のそういうふうな形でもうマスコミがもういっぱいいたんですね
でそこ
をかき分けながら車内に入っていくと
当然のことなんですけど皆さんかなり暗い顔して
自分は今後どうなるんだろうどういうふうに生活をしていけばいいんだろう
子供が前たばかりの人もいましたし逆にある程度年を
行かれた傘方は召されるあの行かれた方はあのこれから再就職っていうのはちょっと
難しいよねそういう話が飛び交っていました
私も
実際にその時はの中学3年生娘が中3だったのでちょっとこれからどうしようかなって
確かに不安にはなったんですけど
ただ私が今までやってきたことが雑誌の編集長っていうのを企業の中で出版局の編集
違ってましたのでほとんど自分のネットワークでそれは
作り上げたんですけどまぁこんな
感じであのクリスティーナアギレラとかなんですけども最初私が日本に大きく取り上げ
たと思うんですけどまぁこういう形で自分のネットワークでまあいろいろ
あの
外国の良い文化の情報を発信していましたので逆に今度は考えたときに自分の今まで
会社で看板でやってきたことが今度本当に自分自身の力でいろんなことができるんだっ
て考えたときにものすごくわくわくしてきました
これから何をやろうかな今までの枠にとらわれずにこれから何をやろうかなって考えて
であのその中でやはりでた出てきた答えが
sns を有効活用するということでしたまあ今までは会社のお金で雑誌を作ってそこ
に自分の情報とかああいう条項のせたんですけど今だ
それが全くなくなってじゃあ自分はずの迷宮を作ろう
でそれで最初はツイッターとかブログ facebook を
を
そういうメディアにしてでいろいろ情報を発信していったと言ってたんですけど実は
こういう形でデザインも cg で作ってみて
これをフェイスブックに投稿したところやっぱり世界中からオファーが来たり
あとアーティストさんからやっぱり色々作ってくれとかあとそういうことがご縁で今度
はテレビ
まあ出すよう
プロデュースするようになったりあとあの c 1輸送機っていう自衛隊の後ろから
選手をのせる
あの救うキーがあるんですけどこれの搭乗ルポやってくれという話が出来ました
でそちらのほうあの草常緑をやったところかなり好評で5年間くらい
アクセスの方が1位だったんですけどそれを見たやはりあの
今度は
航空自衛隊だったので今度は戦車に乗ってくれてはいて
いやコスプレの女の子と一緒だったらの痛いんだけどなあっていう話をして
で次に金が潜水艦に乗ってくれという話も家で厄介いくとでべくと外洋に出て行くと1
か月ぐらいに戻ってこれないんだけどはそれもちょっと無理だなっていうこと
まあそういうのが色々着てでその中でも本当に自分の好きなことをやりたいことを
どんどんどんどん発信していくになりました
でそのときに初めて sns って使い方によってはこんなに面白いんだと自分のやっ
ていることを自分のやりたいことを発信していくとそれをいろんな国の人たちが見たり
日本でも
いろんな人たちが見て税まあそれがビジネスになっていくなっていうのを感じました
であのー sns の楽しさというのをそのとき知ったんですけど実はその後大きな
事件って言いますけど大きなできることがあってでその時に初めて
あの sns の本当の力を知ったんですけどそれは実は3.11の東日本大震災です
この時にメールとか電話とかほとんど使えなくなった状態だったんですけどその時に
ツイッターだけは生きてまして
でツイッターで皆さんが主宰時の情報と
か励ましの言葉とかをどんどんどんどん
あげてくるようになったんですねで私たちっていうのは実際に何かしたい
現地に行って何かしたいけど動けないその時にそれを被災地の状況をリスいいとする
だけでそれは周囲になるということをものすごくして
でいろいろ口をリツイートしていったんですけどそれがやはり構造してマジ
大地の子にいろんなものが届いたりとかあと励ましの
励まされたりとかそういう形が結構出てきまして
プレイ for japan という形もう世界中から日本は一つじゃないよ
一人で内容と日本はこれだけがんばってくれみたいなメッセージが届いて本当にそれは
もうあの感動しましたね
それにその twitter のそういう状況を見てあっ
また違う形で sns っていうのはパワーがあるんだなっていうのをその時初めて
知りました
あのまあこれはもう今までアド画像度かそういう世界の sns だったんですけど
そこでまた新たな出会いが実はあったんですけどそれが動画サイトのユーチューブです
youtube の方で私はあの
まあ google が youtube を買い取ってでいろいろ面白いことを
仕掛けていったんですけど
でその中に youtube space っていうのがあってまぁ日本の場合は東京
の六本木にあるんですけどそこに行った時に年前行った時に
ユーチューバーユーチューバーの卵たちがいっぱいいました
そこでコラボレーション行ったり何か近く
泣いたりしてたんですけど本当に来たときはまだ誰も知らない一般の人に近い人が来て
たんですけどそれが本当し1年しないうちにもう cm に出たり
あとあの番組深夜番組でたりで20万円30万人のフォロワーを確保するようになって
きてこの動きは何だろう
音その時にものすごく興味を持ちました
今までブログとかそういうものっていうのは有名人がもうすでにら前がある人たちが
実際に自分のフォロワーさんをそこからどんどん増やしていくっていうのが通常だった
んですけど
youtube に関しては誰も知らない人がいきなり
2サクセスあの再生回数とかがもうどんどん上がっていくんですね
でこの秘密は何だろうこの動画っていうのは何だろうと興味を持ったときに一つ
思い当たったのが
1分間の映像には
180万も自分の情報伝達力があるということです
つまり
文章を書いてで弾冊も本を書いて流すよりもわずか1分の動画
これに勝るものはないです
外国の人たちもたとえばさっきの画像を見て頂いたり音楽聴いたりそういう動画を見て
いただくともうこれはもう言葉関係なくわかります
良いものか悪いのその魅力を私は知って
で東京ボイス tv というちゃんと目を添えてくださいねあとであのチャンネル登録
してくださいで
ん
東京ボイス tb というのを立ち上げてこれは日本の文化
今のリアルの日本の文化を世界中に発信するそれも英語とにを登っていることで作り
ました
そのダイジェスト版をちょっと作ったので見てください
それがさせていうサムライアクションではいたんですけど
うわキッスですね
ロックアーティストの帰趨が日本一がとき
書道との出会いという形で取材させていねん
メスエバーズのにねリグロンなんかも取材させていただける
こちらポルトガルをたんですけど英語と転がる6
あっきーなんですね
アイウマッピーナはいので取材されての独占で私の番組だけなんですけど
を通じたり
あと
ドリフトっていうのが頭文字d をご存知方多いと思うんですけどこのドリフトという
のは実は日本発祥のこれはスポーツ
まぁこんな感じで ir の
本当にそのまあいろいろ水曜はウー撮ってるんですけど
ぜひあみなさんおっしゃるのは本当にお金かかってるんじゃないかあぁかにょいろんな
人が動いてるんじゃない
いいかというふうに皆さん思われるんですけどここだけのほかだけの
品内緒の話なんですけど実は皆さんノーギャラなんです
あの気質でもアッキーナでも実はあのテレビには全然出さなくてこの youtube
の私の番組だけで出演してくれました
というのは何を言いたいかというと自分がそういう個人的なメディアをつくって
で大手と対向ができるということですね
これは本当にものすごく大きな革命だと思っています
また次をちょっと見ていただきたいんですけど
これは実際に自分の東京ボイス tv が世界中でどのように見られているかと言う
これはもうあの youtube のチャンネルでまあそういう
無料で使える
マーケティングツールがあるのでそれでこう
作ってみたんですけど実際にどれだけの時間を見られているか古いとそういうのが売ら
れている国があると出てくるんですねこういう風
それはアジアだオーストラリアならー
っていうところもかなりあるんですけど
でこの中で見られてないところは北朝鮮と中国でスレをや札がに
ぐらいじゃないですけど意外とロシアとかそういうところはすごく見てくれてるんです
ね
カザフスタンとかべきスタンドが出てきましたけど
服に行ったことないんですけどでも実際に興味を持って見ていただいていると
サウジアラビアイラクとか
本当に世界中の国がもう恋の
ウイで受けましたが止まったみたいですけど
あぶり家
嚢胞とかもかなり見られててっ
で
これも止まっちゃってるのが
でまぁあの他にも色々小さいところ見てもらってるんですけど
でそれで私はみなさんにお伝えしたいのがこれが私は雑誌の編集長をやって今までの
ネットワークがあってそういうできたんじゃないかなと思われている方も多いと思うん
ですけど実はこういうのは私は明日今までの経験を
の表にこういう形で出したんですけどみなさんでもできます
っていうのが例えばこういうふうに youtube の英二を見て頂くと本当に
ペットだけ載せてる所とか
まあクルマ好きな方が車とか料理好きな方は料理とですねファッションをつけた方
ファッションだとかそういうふうなページがいっぱいあります
ですので今例えばファッションが好きな方
料理が好きな方今 sns で例えば投稿しているところに+動画っていうのを重ねる
ことによってそこにまた他の人とは違う工夫をすることによってそれが世界中に広がっ
ていく可能性があるということです
それと
またそういうふうにいっぱい見てくれる人たちが出てくると今度は書籍化とか後テレビ
とかラジオとかな出演おかーとかいろんな形で
そういうトータル的な形でどんどんどんどん注目されるようになってきます
ですからその力をみなさんに私は知ってもらいたいと思って今日
こちらの方にまいりました特に動画っていうのは youtube 私 youtube
を中心してるんですけど
まあ今のニコニコ動画もあるんですけどそれをプラスすることによって
で本当にかなりインパクトの強いものができますと
にはやはりまだまだ動画っていうのはみなさん作るのに編集するのにやっぱり難しいか
なとかちょっとあの
またまあ今かかるかなとか思っている方もいっぱいいると思うんですけどそういう理由
で
されてないか方が実はかなりいらっしゃいます
そういう時に自分の名義は自分の興味あること自分のなりたい自分に受かってそういう
ことを作ることによってそれはモス協力のパワーになってそれは自分のだいぶスタイル
も変え
でいけるだけの力を持っています
前自分のライフスタイルを自分自身で作り上げるというおもしろいたのしいですね
私はあの上場企業に入って朝起きた時に倒産してましたから
もう修行というあまり信じてないんですけどでも自分でそういう風な形でまぁ
作り上げることによっ
実は今年3回海外に行っていますイタリアに
1月に入ってで4月にハワイに行って
で5月にグアムに行ってきてでハワイとグアムは全部バケーションです
で明日じつ温泉じゃ行くんですけどまあこういう形で自分の時間というのを自分で
クリエイトして救うことができる
誰もが平等に成功を得ることができる
もうそういう時代はもうすでに始まっています妹のではお金がないとできない
大企業にいないとできないそういうことが結構多かったんですけど今の sn えっと
ですねそういうものをうまく活用することによって他の人と違うことを
さ記事でやることによってそういうことを聖そういうものを手に得られる
今完了にあります
ですから逆に今やらないと置いていかれるということになります
でこれは私はいつもみんなに言うんですけど
できるかできないかではなくて
やるかやらないかですね
話をしててこれできるって言った時にできるかなーって言った時に私は向かってきます
つまりやるつもりがないっていうふうに私は思います
なんでもそうなんですけど最初は外でもやはり素人です
私も動画というものは編集もやっぱり撮影も2年前まではほとんどやったことがなかっ
たです
でも自分で勉強して自分でやれるという自信がやっぱりついたのでそういうことですね
やっぱり皆さんがやっぱり
できないっていうよりも矢田ないうちからできないというよりも
やるかやらないかだけだと思います
で最後になりますが
つまりみんなのあなたがたの夢はもう世界とつながっています
私はこの youtube の番組をつくって実は去年
国際プレートを国際プロジェクト協会というものを立ち上げたんですけどそれが
やっぱり世界中から今見られてて
イタリアのミラノも招待されて来年は大英博物館でこちらのが北斎亭になります
そういうレセプションも紹介されているんですけど要するに一つのことがきっかけで
世界につながればそこからどんどんどんどん広がっていくということですね
クルーゼ機皆さんに知っていただきたいと思います今日はありがとうございます